und wir sprechen jetzt über eine tat
nach der deutschland der atem stockt er
der gerade erst 19 jahre alte marcel
hesse tötet mit dem messer er tötet
seinen neun jahre alten nachbarsjungen
jaden und kurz danach auf seinen
bekannten in 22 jahre alten christopher
ein brutaler doppelmord mein größter
fall sagt unser bild chefreporter frank
schneider und erhard für bild jetzt
diese beeindruckende doku gemacht über
den killer von herne
mein name ist von schneider ich bin seit
28 jahren journalist unter 20 jahren
chefreporter bei bild
für immer schon polizeireporter bei
vielen terroranschlägen schweren
verbrechen und auch bei amokläufen
schade aber ein fall für mich nie
losgelassen hat weil er so sinnlos ist
der fall des herne killers der zwei
menschen getötet hat
[Musik]
daraus entwickelte sich einer der
spektakulärsten fahndungen und in
kriminalfällen überhaupt ich hier erlebt
haben
die polizei in nrw jagt seit gestern
abend an den mutmaßlichen kindermörder
er ist 19 jahre alt 1 meter 75 groß sehr
schlank und trägt vermutlich
tarnkleidung
was ich mir damals natürlich überhaupt
nicht habe vorstellen können dass eine
der spektakulärsten fälle in meinem
reporter leben werden würde insbesondere
weil der täter hinterher mit seinen
taten im internet angegeben hat er hat
fotos gepostet er hat neue taten
angekündigt hinter dieser tür von
hausnummer 30 c
dort wurde jake mit 52 messerstichen
getötet was der hesse hatte ihn rüber
gelockt denn er wohnte direkt hier neben
nur wirklich 20 schritte entfernt
[Musik]
hatte ich dann geweckt zur schule und
dann sagte er mir dass er das ist
nämlich so gut ginge das normale
schmerzen hat und
aufgrund dessen hatte ich den frühen
abends dann auch nicht mit gelungen zum
einkauf hier sagt er ist okay dann warte
ich auf dich als von hause kommen oder
nicht mehr daran unter den hintern
gehört dass dann auch prompt schaltete
gefragt hätte ob jay rüber kommen kann
die leiter festhalten und leiter
aufstellen
wir haben das gesucht haben gesehen dass
das rauskommt der leuchte war
nach der geschoss bin ich dann im keller
geblieben nach überall gut und es lagen
stücke teile wie auch immer man das
nennen wird dann hat er einen fußmarsch
hingelegt wir haben hubschrauber fliegen
lassen hunde sind eingesetzt worden
leider haben wir massiv hesse nicht mehr
erwischt er brauchte nur diese fünf bis
sechs kilometer zu einem freund will ich
gar nicht mehr sagen zu einem bekannten
den er wohl aus collection zeiten kannte
denn christopher
und hat ihm dann wohl die geschichte
erst einmal meine eltern sind umgezogen
ich komme ja alles noch nicht so klar
kann ich möglicherweise mal für zwei
drei tage bei mir übernachten
ja und irgendwann ist wahrscheinlich
dass dieser christopher morgens wach
geworden und wie junge menschen das
machen man schaut mal kurz ins netz und
dann sieht er das foto seines kumpels
masse lässt der direkt neben ihm noch
schläft
[Musik]
weckt info und ja ich glaube das war das
todesurteil
der junge mann ist sicherlich grausam
gequält worden also wieder eine
widerwärtige tat die auch hier passiert
ist was herr jesu wurde quer durch die
republik mehr oder weniger verfolgt und
er versteckte sich die ganze zeit in
dieser wohnung und am ende war es dann
so dass irgendwann keinen ausweg mehr
sah hat in der wohnung feuer gelegt nur
200 meter entfernt vom letzten tatort
ging marcel hesse an dem abend genau
dieses stück hier auf dem gehweg zu
diesem bisher vorne und stellte sich
dort er sagte damals zudem wird ich bin
der gesuchte marcel rufen sie die
polizei
hinten ein golf
befanden sich neben um die gesunde
wirkung
verantwortlich
was dann an diesem donnerstagabend der
erlösende anruf kam wir haben ihn und
ich glaube das ganze präsidium nicht nur
das präsidium in buchen sondern auch
dortmund und auch die bevölkerung war
heilfroh diesen menschen versorgen
[Musik]
mein größter fall sagt also unser bild
chefreporter frank schneider über diesen
fall über den herr killer und seine
beeindruckende doku sehen sie morgen
abend direkt im anschluss an achtung
verhandlung hierbei bild live um 22 uhr
[Musik]